[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: So Jeff, Jeff
is an associate professor
of Raza Studies and Education at
San Francisco State University.
He is also the founder of Roses
in Concrete Community School,
which is a community-responsive
lab school in East Oakland.
He's the founder of the
Teaching Excellence Network.
And in case that wasn't
enough, the community
Responsive Education Group.
He's also worked with google.org
frequently over the years,
and several members of
that team are here today.
They were really excited
to get to see him again,
which is always a good sign.
As a classroom teacher
and a school leader
in East Oakland for
the past 24 years,
his pedagogy has been
widely studied and acclaimed
for producing uncommon levels
of social and academic success
for his students.
Dr. Duncan-Andrade
lectures around the world
and has authored two books
and numerous journal articles
and book chapters on effective
practices in schools.
In 2015, he was tapped to be
a commissioner on The National
Commission on Teaching &
America's Future, and in 2016,
was part of a group of educators
invited to the White House
on National Teacher
Appreciation Day.
That's going to be a theme
amongst our keynote speakers
of today.
He was invited by
President Obama.
Duncan-Andrade has
also been ranked
as one of the nation's
most influential scholars
and by Ed Week's Public
Influence Rankings
over the past three years.
His research interests
and publications
span the areas of urban
schooling and curriculum
change, urban teacher
development and retention,
critical pedagogy, and
cultural and ethnic studies.
He works closely with
teachers, school site leaders,
union leaders, and
school district officials
to help them develop
classroom practices and school
cultures that foster
confidence, self-esteem,
and academic success
among all students.
He holds a PhD in social and
cultural studies in education
and a bachelor of arts
degree in literature,
both from UC Berkeley.
So thank you so much to
Jeff, and please welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE:
Good morning.
AUDIENCE: Good morning.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE:
That's way better
than my high school class.
[LAUGHTER]
So the talk that I was
asked to do today really
emerged probably about 18
months ago as the result of work
that I'd been doing for the
last five to seven years
pretty consistently, which is
I'm consistently getting called
by districts, by schools,
by charter groups,
by orgs like Google,
like Facebook to help
them think through their equity
plans or their equity efforts.
So I'm in a room
full of educators,
and I'm quite certain that
your district or school
group is also now
all about equity,
because this is all the rage
all over the country, right?
We're going to do equity.
So the first thing that
I typically say to people
is that if you have an equity
office or an equity officer,
then you know you
don't have equity.
[LAUGHTER]
Because equity is everybody
on deck all the time.
Everybody's an equity officer,
or nobody's an equity officer.
Now you've got to
start somewhere, right?
So you're probably going
to start with an equity
officer or an equity
office or an equity plan,
and this is usually the
place where I get inserted.
So I get asked to be a
thought partner, a consultant,
a co-constructor of
districts' equity plans.
And so I've been doing this
now for quite some time.
And it got to the point where
it was so common that when
I was having these
conversations and reading
these strategic plans that I
would see these two words used
interchangeably, that I decided
that I wanted to develop
a talk that helped
people disentangle
the concept of
equality and equity.
Because equality and equity
are fundamentally different,
and what I find in
a lot of schools
that are saying they're trying
to pivot towards equity,
they use these terms
interchangeably
because they haven't
actually spent the time
to understand what
equity means, and how
fundamentally different an
equitable approach to schooling
in this nation would be than
an equal education system.
Now how do we even
land on a conversation
about an equal education system?
What's the Supreme
Court decision?
AUDIENCE: Brown v. Board.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE:
OK, Brown v. Board.
What year is that?
AUDIENCE: 1956?
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: 1954, OK?
Brown v. Board.
Brown v. Board,
Supreme Court decision
legislated against another
Supreme Court decision.
So we had to say that
we were committed
to equality because why?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: Because
we were committed to inequality
before, formally, right?
And what Supreme Court
decision was that?
AUDIENCE: Plessy
versus Ferguson.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE:
OK Plessy v. Ferguson.
Plessy v. Ferguson
Supreme Court decision
legislated racial segregation
as the law of the land, right?
Plessy said-- the
Plessy decision
said that separate is equal.
That's why we have Brown.
So we get to 1954, and
the Brown decision says,
no, separate by
definition is unequal.
We are now in 2017.
So six-plus decades of
a national commitment
to an equal education system,
to desegregated, racially
desegregated education system.
Six decades.
Highest policy body
in the land has
said that racial segregation
in schools is illegal.
Six decades plus in.
Any guesses on how
much progress we've
made on racially
desegregating city schools?
You just jumped right
in with the settle, OK?
AUDIENCE: Negative.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: Negative.
You think-- what?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I think
it's gotten worse.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: You
think it's gone backwards.
Let's do "The Price is Right."
You can't actually bid negative
on "The Price is Right,"
so you're out.
[LAUGHTER]
Anybody think we've
made any progress?
5%?
10%?
OK, your hand went up.
OK, you're in the game now.
AUDIENCE: You brought
yourself in the game.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: Yeah, you
brought yourself in the game.
OK, what do you think?
How much?
5%?
10%?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: 10%.
OK, anybody want to go higher?
AUDIENCE: I say 20%.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: 20%
racial desegregation.
AUDIENCE: 21%.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: 21%.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, now we got the game going.
Now we got the game going.
OK.
No.
You're right.
Negative.
No you didn't say negative.
You said zero.
AUDIENCE: I said negative.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: Oh, OK.
All right.
You're right.
You win.
[LAUGHTER]
It's the new "Price is Right."
City schools are more
racially segregated
now than they were
before the Supreme
Court said that's illegal.
There's a man named
Gary Orfield who's
considered one of the nation's
leading educational historians.
Lawyer by trade, he's at UCLA.
He was at Harvard
for a long time.
When he started this
project, he started
the Harvard Civil Rights
Project, which every--
on every decade anniversary
of the Brown decision,
his research team
releases a report
that tracks the
progress of our efforts
to racially desegregate schools.
On the 60th anniversary of
Brown, he's now at UCLA.
So of course, the project is
now called the UCLA Civil Rights
Project.
[LAUGHTER]
And on the 60th
anniversary of Brown,
they release their
latest report,
and the data reveals that
schools are now more racially
segregated.
We've gone backwards.
That, y'all, is the
value of a policy.
We cannot policy
our way out of this.
Now that doesn't mean
policy doesn't matter.
Y'all are educators.
I'm a 25-year vet
of the classroom.
I know policy matters.
I know my life
was very different
when we had No Child Left
Behind than it was before we
had No Child Left Behind.
There's always been a bunch
of children left behind.
[LAUGHTER]
So the pivot from
an equal education
system, which we have
failed miserably at--
and everyone in this
room knows because it's
the worst-kept secret
in the country.
Everyone in this room knows that
wealthy children, middle class
children that attend
public schools
attend public schools
that are fundamentally
different than the schools
that poor children attend,
the children of color attend.
Everyone knows that.
And equality, an equal education
system is like "Sesame Street"
shit.
One for you, one for me,
one for you, one for me.
And we haven't even
pulled that off.
And now we're talking
about pivoting to equity.
And equity's a much different,
much more complex lift.
So if you go move
to equity, you've
got to first really
invest in understanding
the difference between
an equal education system
and what it's produced for
us and an equitable education
system and what its potential
is to produce for us.
Now the way I've come
to understand this,
and probably at the deepest
level of my understanding
is because I have
a live experiment
in my home about the difference
between equality and equity,
because I have twin boys.
These are my sons,
Amaru and Taiyari.
And I shit you not,
I'm not making this up.
I dare you to even
try to make this up.
Last night, I'm on the
phone because I'm--
if you look at my
car right now, you're
going to see a suitcase,
because I flew in last night
and then yeah.
All that.
OK.
So I'm on the phone with
my son on my travels home
and he says--
he's about to go to bed.
And I said, what
are you doing, son?
And he said, I'm asking Google
if Han Solo and the Millennium
Falcon and Stormtroopers
and Princess Leia
can all be friends.
[LAUGHTER]
And I said, you're asking who?
And he said-- then
he quotes Bush.
He says, "the Google."
[LAUGHTER]
And I said, son, I'm
probably not going
to be there in the
morning when you wake up.
And he says, why not?
And I said, because I'm
going to the Google.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
And he's so juiced.
And then I get out the
house this morning--
and this is partially
the reason why I'm late--
and I forgot my belt.
And I get down the block,
and I'm like, oh, shit.
I forgot my belt and my
pants are falling down.
I can't be at the Google
with my pants falling down.
[LAUGHTER]
So I go back to the house to get
my belt, and my sons are there.
And my son runs up to me.
He's like, Daddy, it's--
I have-- he's like, did
you go to the Google?
And I said, no, son.
I'm going.
And he says, Daddy, take
a picture with the Google.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, so y'all have--
Googlers, you've got
to help me figure out,
like, what does
that actually mean?
How do you--
[LAUGHTER]
He thinks the Google
is a person, OK?
So I need a person.
Otherwise, my son's going
to be really confused, OK?
So this is my life, OK?
This is my experiment
around the difference
between equality and equity.
Now the boy that I'm
talking about is Amaru, OK?
And Amaru is constantly
thirsty, so much
so that this dude literally
will drop a straw into anything
to try to extract liquid, OK?
In this particular
case, he struck gold.
That's a coconut
he's got a straw in.
And Taiyari is constantly
hungry, so much
so that this dude will
literally store morsels of food
on his shirt for later snacking.
[LAUGHTER]
This is a picture of our family,
first time out the house.
Literally, first time out the
house after the boys were born.
Anybody here have multiples?
OK, so you know exactly
what I'm talking about.
That's real talk, isn't it?
That's literally the first time
we made it out of the house.
Everybody else is like,
oh, come on-- no, for real.
[LAUGHTER]
So anybody here from Oakland?
OK.
So y'all would know that
this is the lake, right?
This is Lake Merritt.
Gathering place for
folks from the community.
So we're out at the lake, and
community members walking by.
Hey, hey, hey.
Can you take a
picture of the family?
It's our first time out.
Can you take-- so
he snaps this photo
and hands me my phone back.
And I'm looking at the
phone, put the boys down.
Looking at the phone, and I'm
like, what the hell is that?
I said, Taiyari, come here, boy.
Come here.
I call him over.
And that is bark from that tree.
[LAUGHTER]
So when I tell you that my
son is constantly hungry,
we're literally talking
about a young brother
that will pull bark off
of trees and eat it.
[LAUGHTER]
OK?
So in this context,
is this equal?
AUDIENCE: No.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: OK.
So you went right to no, OK?
So why do you say no?
AUDIENCE: They're
getting the same thing,
but they're not really
getting-- they're not getting--
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: Whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Is this equal?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
They're getting the same thing.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: Oh, now
you want to change your answer?
[LAUGHTER]
Just make sure you let
kids do the same thing.
So anybody here say
this is not equal?
OK, in the back.
Why do you say
this is not equal?
AUDIENCE: They're
getting the same thing,
but they're not taking
in the same thing.
Your son that drinks will
drink the whole thing,
and your son that eats a
lot will eat the bottle.
[LAUGHTER]
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: So
why is that not equal?
See, your problem
and your problem,
and all those that you
went straight to no,
your problem is that you
ignored the question.
In point of fact, you
actually changed the question.
You changed the question from,
is this equal to is this fair?
But that's not what I asked you.
I asked you, is this equal?
And this is the dictionary
definition of equal.
It is in every way equal.
It is also unfair.
And there is nothing in
the definition of equality
that talks about fairness.
And that's why the pursuit
of an equal education
system in a pluralistic,
multiracial democracy that
is also embedded with a long
history of white supremacy
and male supremacy and hetero
supremacy and class supremacy
and radicalized inequality has
created a fundamentally unequal
society, such that
it's literally
disruptive of a pluralistic,
multiracial democracy.
Equity is the right pivot,
but to pivot towards equity,
you have to
understand two things.
One, it's not a soft pivot.
It's a hard pivot.
It's going to mean hard,
complicated, difficult changes
for you as a practitioner
and for the systems
that we work in.
And part of the reason that that
hard pivot is required of us
is because of the data that six
decades of an equal education
system have produced.
Y'all work in
data-driven systems?
Y'all data-driven?
[LAUGHTER]
I think it's fantastic
that we're data-driven.
We should be data-driven.
But I got here today using my
Waze app, my nav app, right?
So I'm from the 3400
block in East Oakland.
So from 3416 David Street,
I had to put in 111--
AUDIENCE: Java.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: Java.
[LAUGHTER]
That's power when you
can, like, name streets.
111 Java.
And I put that in
there, and then Waze
told me where I needed to go.
So what would have happened if
I had put in the wrong address?
Y'all would still be
on your Chromebooks.
[LAUGHTER]
But I'd still have
been data-driven.
Huh.
Because I still would
have put data in.
It's not about
being data-driven.
It's about being driven
by the right data.
And if you're ending
up in the wrong place
year after year after year
with the same group of kids,
what does that mean?
It means you're looking
at the wrong data.
If you keep looking at the same
data year after year after year
because you're data-driven, and
you keep ending up in the wrong
location, and then you
blame the nav system--
you're pissed at Waze because
it took you to the wrong place
when in fact, you told
Waze where to take you.
If your school is missing
the mark consistently
with the same group of
kids, change the data
you're looking at.
Now here's some data
for us on six decades
of a commitment to
an equal education
system, question mark.
Because it isn't even equal.
It's largely unequal or inequal.
But we have lots
of national data
on the impact of this
commitment to public education
in this country.
And I'll start with this one,
high school graduation rates.
Not long before Arne
Duncan was leaving office,
he was all over CNN,
MSNBC, CBS, ABC,
lauding himself and the
Obama administration
for having created the
highest high school graduation
rate in the history
of the United States.
And at that time, I was
teaching high school
at Fremont High
School, deep East
Oakland, arguably
one of the 10 worst
high schools in the nation.
It's also my
neighborhood high school.
Now I'm teaching English.
And I'm listening to Arne
Duncan, the top elected
official, appointed
official in our field
tell me that it's better
than it's ever been.
And I'm at Fremont
where it's worse
than it's ever been
in my 20 years there.
And I'm, like, having all kinds
of intellectual disconnect.
But you see, the
problem with me is
that I've been trained
in the same institutions
as Arne was trained
in, and so I don't
get fooled by presentations of
data, because this isn't data.
This is a presentation of data.
And so we went and got the data.
And this isn't actually the
map that Arne presented.
This is a re-rendition of the
map with one control group.
All we did was control
for one factor.
Income.
So we split the map
and we said, OK.
What are the high school
graduation patterns
for kids that don't
live in poverty?
So this is actually for
non-low income students.
That's the high school
graduation pattern.
Does this shock anybody?
Probably not, because public
schools in this country
have pretty consistently
and effectively
served the needs of middle
and upper income kids.
That's the graduation map
for kids living in poverty.
Didn't control for race.
We could do this map
for race and it'd
look pretty much like this
for black and brown kids.
But we just
controlled for income.
And I know what
y'all are thinking.
Texas?
[LAUGHTER]
Anybody here in Texas?
[CHEERING]
Uh-oh.
I'd better--
[LAUGHTER]
I'd better kill
all my Texas jokes.
[LAUGHTER]
Normally in California
those go over really well.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm in mixed company right now.
Texas cheats.
[LAUGHTER]
Y'all got caught.
Send them to the White House,
send them right back to Texas.
Kentucky.
Anybody here from Kentucky?
We'll bang on Kentucky then.
We'll leave Texas--
[LAUGHTER]
This is still a
display of data, OK?
It still deserves to
be interrogated, right?
Is Texas actually doing
better with poor kids?
Or are they manipulating
their data, right?
And the Texas educators
themselves are like, hell no,
we ain't doing no
better with poor kids.
And of course, we know this.
But if this is not a national
crisis, pray tell, what is?
The group of children
around the nation that most
need public schools
to serve them
well are being failed
across the board, Texas
and Kentucky excluded.
[LAUGHTER]
That's a national crisis
if we are actually
aiming to be a pluralistic,
multiracial democracy.
Because this is the map
of a social apartheid.
This is radicalized
inequality that
is so embedded across
the nation that it's
interruptive of a pluralistic,
multiracial democracy.
This is our national
income data.
This is not from some
progressive think tank.
This is actually Congressional
Budget Office data.
The United States is
the most unequal society
not in the world, in the history
of the industrialized world.
We are the historical global
champs at income inequality.
This is the corresponding
map for incarceration.
We are not only the global
champs at income inequality,
we're also the global champs
at locking up our own citizens.
No country in the
world locks up more
of its own citizens per
capita than the United States.
In point of fact,
no one's even close.
Not raw in.
I'm not talking
about raw numbers.
I'm talking about per capita, we
lock up more than anybody else.
The second closest
nation state is Russia,
and they're not
even close to us.
There's a great
website called Debt
to Society that's run
by "Mother Jones" that
tracks incarceration
expenditures, investments,
and patterns all over the world.
It's a good point of
entry into discussions
about where we're investing
and where we're not
investing in this country,
and what the rest of the world
looks like.
This is the Global Peace Index.
The Global Peace
Index, like any index,
is worthy of critique
and analysis.
Certainly some things missing.
But just by way of
kind of like truthing
how legit is this index,
the Global Peace Index
is used as the primary index of
peace, justice, and stability
by the UN, by UNESCO, and by the
World Health Organization, OK?
Those are about
as big as you get
in terms of global organizations
that are attentive to peace
in the world.
And every time I put
this up, the same thing
that's happening
right now happens,
which is everybody
stops looking at me
and they start
looking for the US
in the rankings, because the
US is obsessed with rankings.
And you're not finding it,
because we're not there.
We didn't make the top 15.
We're 94.
AUDIENCE: Holy moly.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE:
This is perhaps
the most indicting data of
our public education system
that I've seen.
Because we have every child in
this country for eight hours
a day for 13
consecutive years in
their key developmental years.
Research is clear about the
fact that during those years
that schools have a bigger
influence and more time
with children than
their families.
And yet we have produced one of
the most unpeaceful societies
in the world, despite
all that investment.
The 2016 Index came
out not long ago,
and we're trending
the wrong way.
We're now 103.
And what I find particularly
interesting about our ranking
is who's ahead of us.
Nation states that
we are regularly
on public record for
critiquing their total state
of discontinuity, disarray,
injustice, and lack of peace.
And yet according to
the Peace Index that
is used by the globe's
largest and most
committed organizations to
studying and promoting peace,
we are doing worse than them.
Now I would venture a guess that
few, if any people in this room
live at 103.
In point of fact, most
of us in this room
live somewhere
around the top 20.
Which means what if we're 103?
What does it mean for the
kids that are struggling
the most in your school?
Where do they live?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE:
Yeah, they live at 140.
Because for us to get to
103 in the aggregate when
all these people in
this room live at 20
means that somebody else is
way below 103 to get us to 103.
And that disconnect is what
Bryan Stevenson calls proximity
to pain or a lack of
proximity to pain.
Bryan Stevenson, another
person that Google's made
a lot of investment in.
Consider the nation's
leading death row lawyer.
For my money, has
the best analysis
of race going in the country.
Says that the problem that we
have in this society right now
is that most of the
people that are designing
the solutions for pain
aren't proximate to the pain
that they're trying to relieve.
And when you're not
proximate to the pain,
you come up with solutions that
are most convenient for you
not in pain.
But when you get
proximate to the pain,
the solutions you come up
with are very, very different.
But most of us are
serving children
that are living somewhere around
130 or 140 while we live in 20.
And that disconnect leads us to
create schools that disconnect
the kids that most need it.
How do we get
proximate to the pain
that we're actually trying to
relieve in our service of youth
and families?
1854.
London, England was on
the verge of collapse.
Massive outbreak of
cholera, so much so
that city officials believed
that they would lose the city.
In a last ditch
effort to save London,
they sequestered the leading
medical officials in the city,
locked them in a room, sat
them at a table and said,
you're not coming out
of here until you've
got the solution for
cholera for this city.
They sat in there and knocked
around ideas, strategized,
whiteboarded it.
One of the doctors sitting at
the table stands up and says,
this is absurd.
They said, what do you mean?
He says, every single
solution we come up
with defaults us to cholera.
We're coming up
with ways that we're
going to live with cholera.
How we're going to
manage our suffering.
They said, yeah.
He says, I didn't sign
up to be a medical doctor
to live in a state of sickness.
I signed up to be
medical doctor to create
the conditions of wellness.
And I'm OK with
treating sickness,
but that's not the end game.
The end game is total wellness.
They said, well, you're
not being realistic.
You're not looking at the data.
And I hear this said to school
leaders and classroom teachers
all the time when we start
talking about a radical pivot,
fundamentally
changing what we do
on the day-to-day
in schools, how
we interact with the
children that we continually
fail to serve.
Hard pivots.
I hear them told that
they're not being pragmatic,
that they're not
looking at the data,
just like they told
this medical doctor.
So he looks back
at his colleagues
and he says, if
that's what it needs
be part of your
medical association,
I don't want to be part of
your medical association.
And they said, cool.
Showed him the door.
That medical doctor's
name was John Snow.
No, not that John Snow.
[LAUGHTER]
That John Snow.
John Snow hits the
streets and becomes
an ethnographer of the
community he aims to serve.
Study after study for
the last four decades
suggests that the most
successful educators in service
of the nation's most
vulnerable youth
are first and
foremost ethnographers
of the communities
that they serve.
They are on the streets
when the sun go down.
They're on the streets
on the weekends.
They're in the homes.
They're in the lives of the
people they aim to serve.
And they're students of those
families in those communities.
They're researchers,
just like John Snow.
John Snow said, we don't
have the right data.
I've got to get better data.
So he starts
interviewing everybody
that he can that had cholera,
and everybody that he could
that didn't have cholera,
and he collects data.
And what John Snow found in his
data is a researcher's dream.
He found a perfect binary.
He found causal.
What John Snow found is
that every single person
in London that had cholera
drank from that water fountain.
And every single person
that didn't, didn't.
So John Snow got a saw,
and he cut off the handle,
and cholera stopped.
London saved.
Cut off the handle of an
equal education system.
That pump is poison.
It has created one of the most
radically unequal democracies
that we've ever seen.
Pivot to equity.
The equity conversation
means that if you're hungry,
you get food.
If you're thirsty,
you get water.
If you're hella thirsty,
you get hella water.
[LAUGHTER]
In an equity paradigm, you get
what you need when you need it.
This is the big commitment
for the pivot to equity.
The mistake in Brown, 1954--
a lot of folks don't
know there's actually
two Brown decisions.
There's Brown v. Board (1)
and Brown v. Board (2).
Why did we have to
re-legislate the legislation?
Why did we need a
second Brown decision?
Why did the court revisit
its first decision?
Because we weren't
making any progress.
They said, what the
hell's going on?
We legislated racial
desegregation.
It's not happening.
What is going on?
And they went back and they
looked at their decision.
And what they found is
that in the decision,
they didn't say when.
They just said, we will do this.
So Brown v. Board (2) produces
perhaps the most famous line
in the Brown decision.
"With all deliberate speed."
When?
Well, apparently, that
means backwards first.
If you're going
to do equity, make
sure you say when
you're going to do it.
By when will that group of kids
have a different experience
in your classroom, in your
school, in your programs,
in your community?
Because if you don't say
when, then you'll just wring
your hands when you don't.
Because you're not on
the hook for anything.
You'll talk about how
hard you're trying.
We tried this, we tried that.
We hired this person,
we hired that person.
No results.
Very same thing we find
intolerable with our children.
You must produce results.
We model that for them
as adults in schools.
We hand-wring.
But you put yourself
on the hook when
you say when you're
going to do these things.
By this date, we
will have this done.
By this date, this data
will look this way.
And you may miss the mark.
But now it's power
that's on the hook.
It's power that's accountable.
And it's power that's often the
least accountable for change.
So put yourselves on the hook.
Then you earn the
right to really push
children and families
to come along with us.
Now this is not anything
particularly new.
Maslow, 1943.
1943.
Of all the schools
that are in this room,
I would stake my career on
this statement, that there
is nothing being used in your
schools that has the research
base of Maslow.
Seven-plus decades
cross-disciplinary.
Public health, social
epidemiology, neuroscience,
the medical field, child
development, psychology all
agree.
Yep.
He's right.
So if your school is both
data-driven and research-based,
start with Maslow.
Every time you get
stuck with a kid,
every time you get stuck with
a family, start with Maslow.
Start at the base.
Food, clothing, shelter,
safety, basic needs.
We know from all of those
fields that if a kid shows up
hungry, what can't they do?
AUDIENCE: Learn.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: OK?
They can't engage.
They can't engage around
anything but their hunger.
If a kid feels unsafe--
I see all these safety
plans for schools,
and the only thing
they're talking about
is physical safety.
Physical safety.
And what that presumes is that
all the other layers of safety
are de facto, and they're
not for kids of color.
They're not for
language learners.
They're not for girls.
They're not for your
lesbian, gay, trans kids.
They're not.
Those safeties, those identity
safeties are not de facto.
So physical safety,
super important,
but so is identity safety.
Are the children safe
to show up and be
who they really are culturally,
linguistically, sexually?
Because if they're not,
what can't they do?
Can't learn.
If you're unsafe, you can't--
we know this.
There is no debate
in the research
field about these things.
And yet the
transference to schools
has not happened in a way
that is true and authentic
and embedded wall to wall,
tip to finish, edge to edge.
Because we push off
of this and we get
sucked into Pearson and
Houghton Mifflin and Common
Core, when this is Common Core.
And you know who knows this?
Wealthy schools.
This is where they always start.
Are kids safe?
Are they clothed and fed?
Do they have a sense
of love and belonging?
Do they feel good
about themselves?
Basic stuff.
And when the basics are
met, it is a biological fact
that the human being
will self-actualize.
If you have children
in your schools,
if you have teachers
in your schools
that are not
self-actualizing, we
are crystal clear in
the research about why.
Something underneath it is
unstable or under attack.
It has nothing to do with
whether the kid's black, brown,
purple, pink, tall,
short, fast, or slow.
What we know in the research
is that any human being who
has their basic
needs under attack
will not consistently
self-actualize.
What that means is this.
No child that you
serve is broken,
so don't try to fix them.
We're spending all
this time trying
to fix stuff that ain't broke.
Didn't your mama ever tell
you if it ain't broke--
AUDIENCE: Don't fix it.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE:
Don't fix it.
Don't fix these kids.
There's nothing wrong with them.
There's something wrong
with this society.
There's something wrong with the
systems we're putting them in.
That's what has to be fixed.
So when a kid is off the
mark, become a bulldozer.
What we know in the research
is the most effective teachers
of vulnerable youth
are bulldozers.
And what I mean is that they
figure out what's in the way,
and they clear it
out so that the kid
can be who they already are.
Can you see every child that
you serve as GATE, as gifted
and talented?
Because just [INAUDIBLE].
So y'all get GATE
programs in your schools?
Gifted and talented
OK, just peek this
game for a minute, OK?
If this table is the GATE
table, then they are what?
They are gifted and talented.
Well, what does that
make the rest of y'all?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: Yep.
OK.
Every child is GATE.
Not every child
performs as GATE.
The question for us as
educators is, why not?
Why not?
If talent is equally distributed
throughout the population,
which is what we absolutely
have landed on in all
of our research in neuroscience
and biology and biochemistry,
talent is randomly distributed
throughout the population,
why isn't success?
There must be
something systemically
wrong with the way in
which we cultivate talent,
and schools are a
major engine in that.
And the ways in which we try
to cultivate talent oftentimes
is by fixing kids who don't
fit in in the way that's
convenient for us
instead of figuring out
what we need to
clear out of the way
so the kid can be
who they already are.
That is the mind shift that we
make when we move to equity.
Not everybody's going to get
the same thing at the same time.
You're going to get what
you need when you need it.
And the most vulnerable
youth are going to need more.
A lot more.
This is why Eduardo Galeano
says Western nation states have
built a world upside down.
A world upside down is where
those who need the least
get the most and those who
need the most get the least.
And that is the
working definition
of our current society.
We have to invert
that if we're going
to be a pluralistic,
multiracial democracy.
Those who need the most in
your school must get the most.
And this is going
to be the hard sell.
Those who need the least
are going to get least.
That's the hard sell.
Can you convince
families that have
the most that it's actually
good for their kid for this kid
to get more than their kid?
And in a structured
school where your grade
has nothing to do with your
grade, that's not possible.
How do we create a
collectivity community
that is building our collective
responsibility to one another
where if you have a whole
hell of a lot of food
and you ain't got no food, by
definition, you give it up?
That's a pluralistic,
multiracial democracy.
That's not what we're
norming in schools.
Right now, what
we norm in schools
is if you've got the
answer to the test
and she don't and you give
them to her, you're a--
AUDIENCE: Cheater.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: Cheater.
Beginning in
kindergarten, we norm it.
You share your knowledge,
you share your access
to power and opportunity,
you're a cheater.
It's actually bad for her.
She got to pull herself
up by her boot straps.
Then you'll really learn
the positive of work ethic
and how to-- we're not
building collectivity.
And the research
community is particularly
concerned about this
because of what's
showing up in health
and wellness data
like the Peace Index.
We don't have a peaceful
society, and schools
and norming that just with
basic, structural, day-to-day
functioning.
Now I must say about Maslow,
what Maslow said himself
that the rest of the
nation continually ignores
when they talk about his work.
That Maslow did not come up
with the hierarchy of needs.
Maslow appropriated it.
Maslow took the concept
of the hierarchy of needs
from the Blackfoot
people, Blackfoot nation.
Breath of life is what we call
it in indigenous communities.
It's an inverted triangle where
self-actualization actually
sits on the bottom, and the
ultimate goal, the highest form
of community and collectivity
is cultural perpetuation,
the passing along.
Culture, identity,
language, traditions.
That's a sustainable
nation state.
Because now you must connect
with people in your community
to do that.
You cannot do that alone.
Maslow inverts the paradigm.
Says, yes, that that
is the healthy society.
But we are so far
from that-- in 1943,
we are so far from that in this
nation that we actually have
to start with basic--
we actually have built
a society that we
have to say you have to
feed, clothe, shelter,
and protect children.
That's a messed up
society where you actually
have to say those words,
but that's where we're at.
Maslow says that very clearly
in his early work, right?
He says that the
Blackfoot people have
built a healthy,
sustainable society,
and we're headed in
the wrong direction.
So we've got to
reset and say first,
all children must have food,
clothing, shelter, safety.
Basic needs.
Everybody has to have those met.
Everybody has to have a
sense of love and belonging.
Everybody has to have a sense
of self-love, self-esteem
in order for us to then talk
about collective culture.
It's important that
that is re-narrated
as we talk about Maslow, that
this is not a Western idea.
It's an indigenous idea
that has been largely
attributed to
Western science when
in fact, Western science got
the idea from indigenous people.
Now the second part of the
talk, what I want to do
is armor you up to
go do this work.
I want you to know that
the research is completely
on your side.
In the research
community, we don't even
debate this stuff anymore.
We're just trying to
figure out how to go from--
how to close the
knowing-doing gap.
Because we know.
We actually have really, really
conclusive, good research,
but we're not doing
it on the ground.
That's the gap we've got to
close in this generation.
How do we do what we know
we're supposed to do?
What we find in the research is
the most successful educators
focus on those three
things that I called out
around self-actualization.
Relationships, relevance,
and responsibility.
When the policy rain comes,
they've got an umbrella,
and that umbrella is
called good teaching.
They just throw
that umbrella up,
and they know at the end of the
day, relationships, relevance,
responsibility, and my
kids are going to be fine.
My classroom's going to be fine.
My school's going to be fine.
I'm not going to get caught
up in latest, greatest ideas.
Relevance-- excuse me,
relationships, relevance,
responsibility.
And the research bears
this out time and time
again for four-plus decades.
So I'm going to armor you
up with some of the best
research we have
so you don't even
have to have the debate,
because it's a false debate.
It's a false debate.
It's a debate over
ideology instead
of what's good for kids.
And any time you get into
an ideological debate
with people who aren't
moral, it ends in stalemate.
And our goal with the
research and our practice
is to end the debate.
Because we know what works,
we know how it works,
and we know why it works,
and I want everybody
leaving here armored
up with the best
research we have in the nation
for why those things are true
and with an image burned in your
mind about what it looks like.
So for each of these
three, I'm going
to give you a live look
into a classroom or a school
that we've worked with that are
doing this as well or better
than anybody else on the
planet, because two of them
are actually going
to be international.
So we start with relationships,
because at the end
of the day, if you've taught
for a day, you know this.
The end of the day, teaching
and learning always,
always, always boils
down to relationships.
We keep trying to
change the curriculum,
but we're not changing
relationships.
Curriculum won't save you.
Curriculum matters, but
curriculum won't save you.
At the end of day,
it's going to be,
can we build better
relationships
with the kids and the families
that feel really disconnected
from our institutions?
So Herb Kohl who is
not far from here,
a longtime faculty member at
the University of San Francisco,
wrote this book, "I
Won't Learn From You."
And it's one of my
all-time favorite books,
because it's one of
the only studies--
comprehensive studies we
have of students that fail,
and seeing their failure as
conscious and deliberate.
Yeah.
This flipped my wig, right?
Because Herb says,
how many of you
have kids that
show up to class--
you don't even know what
I'm going to ask yet.
You raise--
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, how many have kids?
How many of you have kids?
Just show a hands.
All right.
Yeah.
All the parents in the room, OK?
Happy Parents Day.
OK.
So how many of you have
kids, students, youth--
OK, sorry, I asked
the wrong question.
It's always on me.
That show up to class,
like damn near every day,
and then you get to marking
period, you get to grading,
and you look, and they've
got straight-up zeros
in the grade book.
How many of you have that kid?
OK?
Herb Kohl says, that's you're
most committed student.
[LAUGHTER]
That's some hard shit to do.
Show up every day
and do nothing.
[LAUGHTER]
Try that one time.
How many principals in the room?
Principals?
OK.
I'm going to do you
dirty right now.
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
So for all the staff
members in the room,
OK, here's what
I want you to do.
All right?
The next time you have
to go to a staff meeting
or PD led by your principal,
here's your goal, all right?
Here's your goal.
I'm giving a very
clear, defined goal.
Learn nothing.
[LAUGHTER]
Some of you are like, shit.
That's every damn time.
[LAUGHTER]
Learn nothing, OK?
Herb Kohl called it
willed not learning.
He says it takes a
conscious effort.
You must will yourself to
sit in school and not learn.
Hey And he came
to understand this
by interviewing the least
successful students.
And what he found is they're
excellent at what they're
attempting to do, and what
they're attempting to do
is protect themselves from us.
And so they come
to school every day
because the other option
is going to lockup.
So they come to school every
day with a conscious commitment
that, I won't learn from you.
And he's like, that
makes no sense to me.
It's brilliant, but it
And he said-- and
one kid says to him,
he says, I don't
care what you know
until I know that you care, and
I know these people don't care.
And it doesn't matter
if we think we care.
Care is not about
what you think.
It's about whether or not
the recipient of your care
feels cared about.
And we've got so
many kids in schools
that don't feel cared about.
That's the starting point.
Basic needs.
Food, clothing, shelter, safety.
Love and belonging.
Interview your least
successful students.
Try to understand
that they are actually
some of your most
successful students,
because they're achieving
exactly what they set out
to achieve.
If we don't understand
that, we can't pivot them
in another direction.
There's wonderful
research on this.
Herb Kohl's a great
starting point.
But the research goes
on and on and on.
This afternoon, I'm going
to be down at Stanford
doing some work
with these folks.
Robert Sapolsky.
He just had a great
interview on NPR.
If you're an NPR fan, you can
hear some of his latest work.
Robert Sapolsky is considered
the world's leading researcher
on stress.
His book, "Why Zebras
Don't get Ulcers,"
is mandatory reading in
every single medical field.
Social epidemiology, public
health, neuroscience, medicine.
Everybody has to read Sapolsky.
I find almost no teachers
have ever read it,
and I actually don't
recommend that you do, OK?
Because this book is, like,
600 pages in six-point font.
[LAUGHTER]
However, there is a
wonderful National Geographic
30-minute documentary
film on his work
that is fantastic that
you can get on YouTube.
OK, it's a great PD.
It's called "Stress,"
the silent killer.
OK.
Brene Brown.
Many people are familiar
with Brene Brown
because her TED Talk blew up.
A lot of folks don't know
that Brene Brown also
wrote a "New York Times"
bestseller called "Daring
Greatly" where she expands
and expounds upon what
you hear in her TED Talk.
So if you-- the TED Talk's a
great primer for vulnerability
and understanding the difference
between sympathy and empathy.
And what we see happening
a lot in schools
in the relationships
with vulnerable youth
is sympathetic relationships.
So what is a sympathetic
relationship?
AUDIENCE: When you
feel sorry for them.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: Right.
OK?
You feel sorry for them.
Does anybody know what
happens to you biochemically
and neurologically when you
have a sympathetic connection
with somebody?
What actually
happens inside you?
Anybody know?
That's what you want to
start understanding better.
Don't understand the
external portrayal.
Understand what's
going on inside.
Because if you change
what's going on inside,
you're going change
what's coming out, OK?
So what's going on inside
your body if I have--
if I have a sympathetic
connection to her,
I feel sorry for you--
I don't know why yet--
what's going on in my
brain and my biochemistry?
AUDIENCE: I mean,
are you at all?
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: Nothing.
Nothing.
No shifts.
What's going on in
her biochemistry?
Nothing.
It's a false connection.
I'm glad I'm not you.
Right?
That's sympathy.
What's empathy?
AUDIENCE: Putting yourself
in someone else's shoes.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: Huh?
AUDIENCE: Putting yourself--
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE:
Putting yourself
in someone else's shoes.
How many have young people
that say, I feel you?
(DEEP VOICE) I feel you, dog.
I feel you.
[LAUGHTER]
They're literally
expressing empathy.
Empathy is, I feel you.
If I have an empathetic
connection to her,
what happens to my neural
pathways and my biochemistry?
Exploding.
What happens to
her neurochemistry?
Exploding, because
it's connection.
I feel you.
I literally feel your pain.
I feel your joy.
That connectedness is
what Brene Brown's work
has helped us understand.
The false connection of
sympathy and the vulnerability
that is required to make
an empathic connection.
And the bioregistry
that we see when
you make an empathic
connection is off the charts.
And what's most
compelling about what
we find that's
happening in the body
when you have an
empathic connection
is your massive release of
oxytocin, the happy chemical.
It is so good for your body
to make empathic connections,
and it's so good
for your body too.
It's really, really
good for your teachers
to learn how to make deep
connections with youth.
It's good for their
longevity in the profession.
The list goes on and on and on.
Nations, leading researchers
all agreeing about the pathway
to relationships, particularly
with vulnerable people
and youth, and why
they matter so much.
There's no debate in the field.
The question-- there's no
debate in the research field.
The question the
practice field has
to get more complex and more
committed to how, when, where,
and why.
Now I'm going to show you a look
in on a teacher's classroom who
does this as well, if not better
than anybody in the world.
His name's Mr. Kanamori's
They made a documentary film
about him when he won the
National Teacher of the Year
in Japan.
So this is also a great PD.
It's called "Children
Full of Life."
Amazing, because it
follows his classroom
over the course of the
year, and it disabuses
people of the belief that
national teachers of the year
don't have conflict
in their classroom.
Because he's got hella beef in
his classroom with the kids.
He gets mad.
He loses his temper.
He gets depressed.
He get sad.
He feels like he's failing.
All the range-- the
gamut of emotions.
And what he says is that I have
the exact same things happening
in my class as every other
teacher in the country.
The difference is I
just react differently.
And I think that there's a sense
that really skilled teachers
have this special pixie
dust that we blow on kids,
and it's all good all the time.
We've got to help all
our teachers understand
that really good teachers,
the most successful teachers
have the same beefs in
their classroom as you do.
They just respond differently.
Don't try to end the beef.
Try to learn how to turn
it into teachable moments.
The meaning is in
the mess, and we keep
trying to sanitize education.
It's a human project,
so by definition, it's
going be messy.
So can you learn
to love the mess?
Because that's where
the meaning lies.
Now you don't want to be
messy all the time, OK?
Because then it's
just messy, right?
There's got to be meaning
coming out of the mess.
So I'm going to introduce
you to Kanamori's class
as a way to literally
burn in your brain
an image of what
it looks like when
a teacher's primary
commitment is relationships.
And we haven't
tested the sound yet,
so I'm going to
see how this goes.
I'm trusting you, Google.
I'm trusting you.
It's supposed to be technology.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Late April, Ren [INAUDIBLE]
comes to class for the first
time in four days.
His grandmother died.
In his notebook, Ren
writes about the death,
the funeral, his loss.
- [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
- They were worried.
They didn't know
why Ren was away.
Now they're moved at his pain
and saddened by his loss.
- [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
- The letter unlocks some
brutal and long-hidden memories.
- [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[CRYING]
- Mifuyu has been holding down
her memories for more than half
her life.
- [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
- She'd been afraid to
talk about her father.
She didn't want
to seem different.
She paid a price.
- [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
- Now at last, she
feels safe enough
to talk about her
missing parent.
- [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
- They're trying to understand.
They all find it painful.
Some find it unbearable.
- [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[LAUGHTER]
- Yo Animoto is the
class spark plug.
High energy, charming.
Now he's remembering the
death of his grandmother.
- [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[END PLAYBACK]
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: That's--
that's master pedagogy.
But what about time on task?
[LAUGHTER]
That's how you get the
highest achievement
patterns in a nation.
Relationships, not
drill and kill.
Because out of
that empathy comes
the deeper learning,
the connection
to the concepts and the ideas.
A reason to read,
a reason to write.
Not for a test.
No one in this room
remembers your test scores.
In the larger scope of your
life, they're irrelevant.
They matter in terms
of gateway access
to institutions and power.
But in terms of building
pluralistic, multiracial
democracy, they have
almost zero value.
So what are we trying to build?
And if it's the
latter, then we've
got to follow the
research and what we know
has the biggest impact on
achievement in practice,
which is relationships.
Second is relevance.
We get those kind
of relationships,
then it's an open question.
What are we actually
teaching these children?
Now I'm in a lot of
schools that bring me
in because they want to do some
iteration of ethnic studies.
They want to be culturally
and community-responsive,
culturally relevant.
I am not a big
fan of checklists,
but I'm going to give
you one right now.
If you want to
check whether or not
your curriculum and
pedagogy in your classrooms
and in your school is culturally
and community-relevant,
here's your checklist.
Does it reflect students'
lives, their communities,
their families, and their
ethnic, cultural, and
linguistic histories?
If it doesn't, the answer's no.
You're not culturally
and community-responsive.
If it does, you're
on a good path.
Well, what that means
is that you're not
going to have the
same curriculum
school to school to school,
even in the same city, right?
That's what it means to be
community and culturally
responsive, is to first
assess, who are the children
and families that I serve?
And what is a
curriculum that connects
to their lives, their
blocks, their families,
and their ethnic, cultural,
and linguistic histories?
That's what it means to
have a relevant education.
And all of those things can be
scaffolded into Common Core.
One of the few
upsides of Common Core
is it actually opens
this window for us
to be much more dynamic
in the way in which we
design and deliver curriculum.
And of course, the
research bears all this out
across fields.
There's no debate about whether
or not cultural and community
relevance matters.
Here's why.
First, what we know
is that in classrooms
where this is
happening, students
have a stronger sense of self.
And we know from the research
both from neuroscience
and from psychology
that there is
a direct connection
between knowledge
of self and self-esteem.
Where did you see self-esteem
in this presentation earlier?
AUDIENCE: Maslow.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE:
Where in Maslow?
It's not at the top.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: Right.
It is the window into
self-actualization.
No human being consistently
self-actualizes
in an aspect of their life
where they do not have
self-love, a sense of esteem.
And we're dealing with kids all
over the country, particularly
kids of color, that have been
taught to hate themselves.
Taught to hate the
color of their skin,
the texture of their hair,
the color of their eyes,
the language they speak, the
neighborhood they come from,
their family history.
That has to be
eradicated in schools.
How many students
graduate from your schools
and say, I love myself?
Because what we know in the
research is that if that's said
and true, because there's
some kids that say they love
themselves that really don't.
But if that's said
and true, that person
is on a trajectory to success.
Self-love.
But I find almost no schools
in the country measured that.
You know what that means?
It doesn't matter.
Because we measure what matters.
If love matters to you, if
self-esteem matters to you,
start metricing it in your
classroom and your schools.
And there are definitely
well-tested measures
for those things.
We also know that there's
a direct connection
between self-esteem and hope.
Hope has become
particularly centered
in conversations in the medical
field around vulnerable youth,
wounded youth, youth exposed
to high levels of trauma
and toxic stress.
Because what the
medical field has found
is that hope is the only
consistent indicator
that they've been able
to track and measure
that directly links
to how well students
navigate through toxic stress.
The higher their hope levels,
the more resilient they are.
There is a very clear metric
for hope, what you can measure.
I use the Children's Hope Scale
in my high school classroom.
It's the only thing
I baseline is hope,
because I know the research.
And I know if I move
the meter on hope,
the reading, the
writing, the tests
will take care of themselves.
And I also know that
if I teach the hell out
of the reading, the
writing, and the tests
and I'm not attentive to hope
that it won't move for the kids
that most need it to move.
Charles Snyder developed
something called the Children's
Hope Scale and hope theory.
It's a very simple
scale that you
can use to track hope
levels in your classrooms
and in your schools.
We know that there's
a direct relationship
between hope and ability to
interrupt stereotype threat.
How many of you have heard
of stereotype threat before?
A few of you?
OK.
How many of you test
kids in your schools?
You guys-- y'all don't test?
I can just leave now then.
You good.
I test kids.
I'm a teacher.
I want to know.
I want to know, do you know?
I want some recall.
OK.
But if you're
going to test kids,
know the research on testing.
Claude Steele developed a
concept called stereotype
threat, because he wanted
to understand-- how many
of you have students who can do
the work and then they sit exam
and they choke?
We now have very clear
neurological science
on why that happens, OK?
Here's what happens,
and here's why
it happens
disproportionately to kids
of color, poor kids, and girls.
It's called stereotype threat.
So what happens when
you sit exam, any exam,
any test that you believe is a
measure of your innate ability,
and the stereotype about
your group is that you're not
innately good at it, you have
a biochemical reaction that
literally fires inside
your brain and interrupts
your neural pathways
so that you literally,
biologically cannot
recall things you know.
Your neural pathways
get blocked.
We have crystal clear
research evidence on this.
So Claude was particularly
interested in why this
is happening for kids of color.
So he releases
all this research.
And probably the
book I'd start with
is a book called
"Whistling Vivaldi."
The way in which stereotype
threat affects kids of color
is very clear to us.
But the larger research
community is like--
Claude's at Stanford.
And they're like, OK, Claude.
Like, if that's
really true, there
are stereotypes about
everybody, so stereotype threat
will affect everybody.
And Claude goes, yeah, it will.
But I'm not interested
in everybody.
I'm focused on kids of color.
Why do I have to prove it
happens to white people for it
to matter for people of color?
You guys go prove that.
They're like, OK, we will.
So they said, if it's
true, then it'll definitely
happen to women.
Claude said, yep, it will.
So they conducted a study
with women mathematicians,
because what's the
stereotype about women
in math and science?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE:
Not innately good at it.
Not part of your genetic makeup.
So he took a group--
or this research team
took a group of women
mathematicians, which
means they can do what?
AUDIENCE: Math.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: Math.
[LAUGHTER]
And they took them through
this series of problem sets,
and they did it just fine,
because they're mathematicians.
And then they sat an exam.
They put the same problem
sets in front of them,
and they said, this
test will measure
your innate
mathematical ability.
Go.
And they all underperformed.
They said, oh my goodness.
Claude might be right.
But there's one final test.
Who's the final test?
AUDIENCE: Men.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: Which men?
AUDIENCE: White men.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: White men.
Because there are stereotypes
about white men too,
aren't there?
White men can't--
AUDIENCE: Jump.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: Jump.
And white--
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Can't dance.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: And she
added in for extra spite,
can't dance either.
[LAUGHTER]
White men can't jump.
White men can't dance.
So UCLA conducts a
study with a group
of white male undergrads who
were all highly accomplished
high school athletes.
Now a lot of people come
to undergrad and say,
I was an accomplished
high school athlete,
and it's not even true.
So they tested it.
Indeed, these young men were
all very skilled, capable,
high-end athletes.
And then they sat an
exam and they said,
this test will measure your
innate athletic ability.
And guess what happened?
They all underperformed.
And the difference
between white men
and some women and
kids of color is
there isn't a stereotype
about white men
not being good at school.
So when they sit exam,
the biochemistry registers
don't shift.
They know they can do school.
There's lots of evidence
they can do school.
But with kids of
color, that question
is always in the back of your
mind, even if you don't say,
this test innately
measures your ability.
You interview kids.
You find out they think
that the test measures
their innate ability.
So Claude is very
clear about what
you can do with somebody who
needs to test kids to interrupt
stereotype threat.
And this is part of
the pattern, but there
are things you can do tomorrow
when you sit kids exam that you
can say that will alleviate
some of that neuro blockage
and will allow them to
perform at the level
that they're actually at.
And this creates
what researchers
call a Pygmalion effect, OK?
The Pygmalion effect is the
self-fulfilling prophecy.
I am whatever you say I am.
Research is crystal clear
that the single biggest
factor impacting student
achievement in a classroom--
anybody know what it is?
Parent income, parent
education, ZIP Code--
AUDIENCE: Teacher expectations.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE:
Teacher expectations.
Study after study after
study reveals this.
Teacher expectation is
the number one factor,
and we have good
research on why,
because teacher expectation
creates a Pygmalion effect.
You are always creating
a Pygmalion effect
in your classroom.
That's a fact, always.
There is always a
Pygmalion effect going on.
The question is whether it's a
positive or a negative one, OK?
The negative Pygmalion effect
is you think I'm not smart,
I must not be smart.
The positive Pygmalion effect
is you think I'm smart,
I must be smart.
And this is what Carol Dweck's
work has lifted up for us.
Now I'm in schools
all over the country
that are misusing
Carol Dweck's work.
Carol Dweck-- how many of you
are familiar with Carol Dweck's
work?
Oh, yeah.
That's what I thought.
It's all the rage.
[LAUGHTER]
Have you been-- checked out
Carol's latest lectures?
She's gone back on the lecture
circuit to rage on schools
for misusing her research.
Because I'm in schools
all the time that say,
yeah, we're working
on growth mindset.
I'm like, yeah, oh, who are
you working on that with?
And they're like, the kids.
We're developing
kids' growth mindset.
Carol's like, oh, shit.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, let me just lay it
out for you plain, right?
Who needs a growth mindset?
AUDIENCE: Teachers.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE:
The grownups.
OK, the grownups.
What Carol Dweck says very
clearly in her research
is that the mindset
of the children
reflects the mindset
of the adults.
So if you want to change
the mindset of the children,
you've got to change the
mindset of the adults.
The growth mindset work
is for the grownups.
And when grownups
have a growth mindset,
kids come along just fine.
So if you're finding
children in your schools
don't have growth mindset,
then work on the adults that
are around them.
We're short on
time, so I'm going
to blow into the third one.
You're not going to get
to see the [INAUDIBLE]..
Sorry.
Hey, you know-- now she's
giving me the two-minute mark.
Or are you throwing
up peace sign?
[LAUGHTER]
We're going to end
with responsibility.
Because at the end of the
day, that's the driver.
Can we hold our responsibility?
Bruce Perry's considered
the nation's leading expert
on child trauma.
So if you are working
with kids that
are experiencing mild to severe
exposure to toxic stress,
they are going to have
trauma registers, OK?
Bruce's book, "The Boy
Who Was Raised as a Dog"
is my primer when I'm
working with schools that
have high levels of trauma.
It is awesome.
His work is awesome,
and this book
is a great PD item for teachers.
You can do one
chapter at a time,
because every chapter's
an independent case study.
And it will literally
change the way
that you interact with kids that
quote, unquote, "misbehave,"
because you'll read their
behavior differently.
And when you read
behavior differently,
you respond differently.
If you see it as misbehavior,
then you'll punish it.
If you see it as the
result of trauma,
then you'll try to heal it.
There's all kinds of
neurology behind that.
Some other light
reading, just in case
you get bored over the summer.
Robert Putnam.
Oxford recalls Robert Putnam
the world's most influential
scholar.
OK, it's not actually "Bowling
Alone" that I recommend.
I put "Bowling Alone" up there
because that's the one that
put him on the map.
He just released another
book called "Our Kids," which
is one of the best
political economist analyses
of the role of public
schools in creating
a social apartheid or a
pluralistic, multiracial
democracy.
Putnam is at Harvard's
Kennedy School.
He concludes that we are rapidly
approaching social apartheid,
if not already achieved it.
"Unnatural Causes" is an
amazing film series from PBS.
I think they now
have eight films out.
It has a great website with
tons of resources for teachers.
It's the largest study ever
connected cross-discipline--
or ever conducted
cross-disciplinary
on the impact of inequality.
It's a global
study of inequality
and its relationship
to health outcomes.
And conclusive field to
field is that the biggest
threat to health on the
planet is inequality.
So if you want a healthy
classroom or a healthy school,
you have to eradicate
all forms of inequality.
No oppression Olympics.
You've got to pay
attention to race.
attention to class.
You've got to pay
attention to gender.
You've got to pay attention
to sexual identity.
to xenophobia, language.
All forms of inequality,
odious, intolerable.
And when that is what
we see in schools,
that's what we'll
see in our society.
Because if for 13 years
you go to an institution
where inequality
is unacceptable,
you become an
adult that believes
inequality is unacceptable.
But the truth is schools
are a social mirror,
and the same
radicalized inequality
that we see in the society
gets normed in schools.
And then last, Michelle
Alexander's "The New Jim Crow"
for my money is
the best analysis
of the relationship between
schools and the prison system.
I want every
educator that I work
with to understand that
writing a referral on a child
is not a benign act.
You put pen to paper, and
we have very clear evidence
that there is a connection
between referral and pathway
to juvie.
And we have very clear
research evidence
that there is a clear connection
between the pathway to juvie
and the pathway to the pen.
Schools have to change the
way we discipline kids,
because we don't.
We punish them.
And discipline and punishment
are not the same thing.
Read Michel Foucault. We
have conflated those things
in schools.
And I guarantee
you, if you start
calling suspension,
expulsion, and office
referrals punishment,
they'll go down.
They'll go down, because
then you're saying,
so you want to punish this kid.
And people-- oh, no, no, no.
I want to discipline them.
OK.
Well, discipline comes from
the Latin discipulus, which
means rigorous repetition--
or rigorous training
through repetition.
Can you give a child rigorous
training through repetition
if they're suspended?
Yeah.
You can give them rigorous
repetition in suspension,
and that's what
happens, isn't it?
There is no evidence
in the research field
that punishment
changes behavior.
There is very clear evidence
in the research field
that discipline
changes behavior.
Discipline is a
process of inclusion.
Punishment is a
process of exclusion.
Do you discipline kids
or do you punish them?
Make sure you understand
the difference.
Wayne Yang wrote a great article
on this for educators, Y-A-N-G.
So I'm going to end giving you
a live look into my classroom,
just in case you think I'm
up here just talking shit.
[LAUGHTER]
Which I mostly am,
but I actually--
I actually do the work too.
I've been a teacher
in my community
for-- this will be my 25th year.
I hear I get some kind of,
like, tinfoil watch for that
this year.
[LAUGHTER]
So this is from my high
school English classroom
a few years back.
This young lady that
you're going to hear from
is actually my
neighbor, so I literally
teach my neighbor's kids.
She's also from the 3400 block.
This was at Fremont.
And this is my
second year with her.
And I want you to
understand that,
because this stuff that I'm
talking about doesn't happen--
[FINGER SNAP]
--like that.
That your responsibility
is a commitment over time.
That young people
will not become
who we want them to be tomorrow
just because we love them
a little bit harder,
particularly the most
wounded and vulnerable youth.
They're going to show
up with their wounds
and their vulnerability,
and the more we
love them, the more they're
going to expose that--
expose that to us,
and the harder it's
going to be to love them,
because it's painful to love
somebody who's wounded.
So we've got to support
each other in that work.
We can't isolate
teachers either.
Now I'm also going to
say about this video
that you're about to see that
it may trigger some of you
because of what she
chooses to share.
And if you get triggered, please
take the space that you need.
And if somebody at your
table gets triggered,
acknowledge their humanity.
Check in on them.
Lay hands, skin to skin.
It's important.
When I think about my
responsibility as an educator,
I think about her, and I
think about this story.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- My poem is called "More
scars than birthdays."
"If I had a gun
pointed to my head
and my life flashed
before my eyes,
I would see the times I
would smoke with ma cousins,
drinking, smacking, doing powder
till I knew I was too gone.
Cheating on my boyfriend with
my ex because he would tell me
he still loved me.
Lyin to the people I
love, hurtin the people
that care about me the most.
And then I would
see the reason why.
I would see a little girl--"
[CRYING]
- You can do it.
We're with you.
[CRYING]
- "I would see a
little girl getting
raped at the age
of four years old.
She didn't know what to
do or who to talk to.
She was so afraid that she
would cry and not tell anybody.
She stayed silent.
I would see four years passing
by, rape after rape after rape.
I would see an
eight-year-old girl
with more scars than birthdays.
I would see a girl--
no.
I would see a 13-year-old
girl getting raped
by her first real boyfriend.
I would see a girl who didn't
know how to love herself.
I would see me.
And if I had a gun
pointed to my head,
and I had minutes left to live,
I would tell that little girl,
it's OK to tell your mom.
It's safe to cry, go through
your pain so you can heal.
Drugs will not heal your
pain, will not block it out.
Love yourself.
One day: trust
somebody, love somebody,
let yourself be loved.
If I had a gun
pointed at my head,
I would cry and tell
15-year-old me 'I love you,
don't regret your mistakes.'
Because I've learned that
my mistakes are the lessons
I needed to learn so I could
create a better future."
[APPLAUSE]
[END PLAYBACK]
That girl's in your class.
That girl's in your school.
That boy's in your class.
That boy's in your school.
That is not the question.
The question is whether or not
your school and your classroom
creates the space for them to
narrate that truth and be held.
She's 16 years old.
She's a sophomore.
She's standing in front
of her peers saying that.
How do we create
classroom youth cultures
where they hold
each other, where
that doesn't become chisme, that
doesn't become cyberbullying?
That's not all over
the bathroom walls.
But instead, they're
calling out, say, go.
We got you.
It's OK.
And they're saying, go ahead.
We got you, because they
know they're up next.
They're going to be up
there telling their story.
And their story looks
just like her story.
When young people
are doing that,
they're a lot less likely
to sit on a trigger
and point it at somebody
that looks just like them.
The only way you
can pick up a heater
and pointed at somebody
that looks just like you
is if you hate yourself.
You want to stop violence
in your neighborhoods,
you want to stop rape, you want
to stop pillaging, violence,
suffering, center love.
Create the conditions
in your school
where children are able to
heal from their woundedness
and learn to love
themselves by loving others.
That will transform this
nation state from 103
to top 20 in peacefulness.
What we do every day
around love matters.
I don't give a shit
about your test scores
if your students
leave your institution
and they don't love themselves.
We're building a nation full
of educated [INAUDIBLE]..
The creators of the collapse
of the housing industry
and the banking
industry all went
to the most elite
universities in the world.
That can't be the solution.
We must be missing
something in what we're
centering if they can read
and write and do math and then
create paradigms whereby
they exploit other people.
We've got to put ourselves
on the hook for that.
How are we going to create
a group of young people
that will build the nation
that we've rhetorically
committed to, but in reality
have not built at all?
I'll end with the teachings
of the people of this land,
teachings from the
Cherokee community,
which also reoccur
across many indigenous
communities, this story.
It's a story about little
boy out in the front yard
playing around.
He comes running in the
house, and he runs up
to his Abuelita, his grandma.
He says, Abuelita,
I feel like there's
a war going on inside my head.
And she says, there is, mijo.
He says, who's
fighting, Abuelita?
She says, the two wolves.
He says, well, who are
the two wolves, Abuelita?
And she says, one wolf is rage,
avarice, greed, selfishness,
violence.
He says, who's the
other wolf, Abuelita?
She says, the other wolf is
garino, familia, love, empathy.
He says, who wins, Abuelita?
And she says, the one you feed.
Those wolves are inside
every child you serve.
They're inside every
person in this room.
They're inside every staff
member you work with.
They're there.
If we can change the wolves
we're feeding in ourselves,
we will change the wolves
the young people are feeding.
And when we do that, we're
on the path of the thing
that I think almost everybody
in this room set out
to try to build when
you were dumb enough
to become an educator.
[LAUGHTER]
If I can support you in
any way on that journey,
please don't hesitate
to reach out.
Put my contact info back up.
If you want this slide deck, if
you want any of the resources,
if you want the second
tier of resources
that come after you've
read all this stuff, please
don't hesitate to reach out.
We will not build this
transformation in isolation.
This has to be both an
individual and a collective
and a national commitment
to change in the way
that we do education
in this country.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
SPEAKER 1: All right.
So Jeff has been nice
enough to offer to answer
a few of your questions.
So we'll take
another few minutes
and give you all an opportunity.
I can bring this around.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE:
Yeah, in the back?
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
coming here and talking today,
first of all.
One of the things
we always get asked
is, what are some of
the practical things
we can bring back?
Even though it's a
long journey, but just
to start the ball
rolling with some things
that teachers can grab on to.
Similarly to the hope survey
that you mentioned, something
along those lines,
and where to go
to get some of those resources.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Or exercises.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE:
So the resources
that I lifted up
in this talk, when
I read these texts, they
immediately resonated
for me in my classroom.
Like, I could
apply it right now.
Like, oh.
It changed the way
I saw certain kids.
So it really depends on
the problem of practice
that the educator
is trying to unlock.
But typically, that's
with, like, I'm
trying to figure out how
to connect to this kid
that I can't figure out
how to connect to, right?
That's typically the
biggest challenge
that I see with teachers.
This kid is disruptive, won't
do the work, they're defiant,
whatever the story is.
And so depending on the
context in which you teach,
I would start teachers off
either with Perry's book,
OK, Bruce Perry's book, "The
Boy That Was Raised as a Dog,"
because inevitably what's
happening with that quote,
unquote, "defiant" kid is that
they're carrying a trauma load,
right?
Their neurology and
their biochemistry's
all off whack because they're
not feeling safe, right?
And so to the degree that a
teacher can understand that--
and Perry helps you
understand, like,
what's going on inside the kid.
And when you understand what's
going on inside the kid,
then you read the outer
portrayal of those things
differently.
So the other thing that
really impacted my classroom
practice a lot was "Unnatural
Causes," that film series.
Because there's
also a website that
hosts it that has lots and lots
of very practical curriculum
resources, trainings, all
these things that teachers
can access.
But at the end of the day, I
think typically the advice that
I give to teachers that are
struggling with a particular
student is don't try to fix
that problem in the classroom,
because you almost
certainly can't.
So can you create the conditions
to build a relationship
with that child outside
of the classroom?
And the truth is that
every single teacher
I've ever worked with already
has the skill set they need.
They're not lacking, OK?
Because every teacher
that you might
be working with that's
struggling with something,
they have a good relationship
with somebody in their life.
So what is that evidence of?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE:
That they know
how to build a good
relationship, right?
And so what's happening
is that they're
mismatching who they are in
that positive relationship
and who they are with that kid
that they're in conflict with.
And because they have
power in the relationship,
they're wanting the kid
to change first, right?
When this kid shows
up properly, right?
When they show up with respect,
then I'll be their teacher.
That's actually a violation
of our moral responsibility
as a teacher.
In New Zealand,
they actually have
to sign-- teachers have to
sign the Hippocratic oath.
Y'all know what
the Hippocratic--
anybody not know what
the Hippocratic oath is?
That's the oath
that doctors take.
And what's the
main line in there?
AUDIENCE: Do no harm.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: First
rule, do no harm, right?
And so I start there
with teachers, right?
What is-- have them analyze
the best relationship
they have in their life.
What are the components of it?
How do they act?
And specifically, how do
you act under conflict?
Because we romanticize our
relationships in this country.
We act as if conflict
is a bad thing.
And the truth is that the
tightest relationship you have,
whether it's with your
homies or with your partner
or with your children,
there's always conflict.
And we have this story that
we tell ourselves that love
is the absence of conflict.
Because love in this society
is super pollyannish.
It's all based on
"The Notebook."
[LAUGHTER]
Everything's going to
be OK in the end, right?
No, it's not.
Love is not the absence
of conflict, OK?
Give this nugget
to your teachers.
Love is not the
absence of conflict.
Love is the presence of conflict
with the courage, character,
and commitment to
find your way through.
And that is the
main divide I find
between the most successful
teachers and the least
successful teachers, is the
least successful teachers abhor
conflict.
They resent it.
They want it to go away.
They want no mess.
And what I tell those teachers
is, get an office job.
If you want predictability,
get the hell out of teaching.
I've been teaching 25
years, and the minute
I think I got it licked, I get
one in the back of the head.
Like, no way!
How'd you get me?
That girl that you heard,
when she started my class,
I was starting my 18th year.
I had all these awards.
And she's my neighbor.
And one of my points of
pride in my 18 years--
pride cometh before the--
AUDIENCE: Fall.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: Mm-hmm.
So here it comes.
One of my points of pride was
that in 18 years in deep East
Oakland, I'd never had a
fight in my class, ever.
And the first day, that girl
hops off a fight in my class.
My damn neighbor--
[LAUGHTER]
--breaks my streak of 18 years.
And a lot of teachers would
have resented her for that,
and I loved her for it,
because she forced me to grow.
And all those awards--
when I get awards,
I put them in boxes,
because that's who I was.
It's not who I'm becoming.
And she reminded me of that.
You've got to become
somebody else right now,
because I'm in your class.
Right?
And a lot of teachers,
they'd have all awards,
do you know who I am?
That same class two years
later, Harvard brought me up,
and me and Arne Duncan
were the keynote speakers.
Arne Duncan went
first, and then I
went on and explained why
everything he said was wrong.
[LAUGHTER]
And so I fly back from Boston.
I get in, like, 2:00
in the morning to SFO.
Go back to my house,
and first period I'm
in my class teaching
11th grade English.
And this boy in my class,
like, just gives me the--
like, to the point
where I literally
started having homicidal
thoughts about him.
Like, in the moment.
Like, dude, I'm
going to kill you.
And my first reaction to
him when he was doing this
was, I almost--
I almost said this.
I almost said, do
you know who I am?
[LAUGHTER]
Like, I was just with
Arne Duncan, you asshole.
[LAUGHTER]
And then I remember,
he doesn't give a shit
about Harvard or Arne Duncan.
He's showing up with
all his woundedness.
Can you hold me like this?
Because you say
you care about me.
And what I try to get
teachers to understand
is the most wounded children
speak the most truth,
and we resent them for it.
Because the most
wounded children
don't even try to
cover it up anymore.
They reveal to us the darkest
corners of our society.
That's what that girl told
you, that she showed me
on the first day.
I'm wounded.
And I know who you think you
are, 18-year vet with all
your awards.
Your reputation ripples
throughout the neighborhood.
And for that reason,
I'm coming in here.
I'm going to fuck up your
class on the first day.
[LAUGHTER]
Because everybody
says, you're Jeff.
Everybody says, you
love all your students.
Everybody says,
you'll go to juvie.
You'll go to jail.
You'll go to the streets.
Everybody says, but you
won't do that for me.
You won't do that for me.
I know you won't, and I'm going
to prove it on the first day.
I'm just going to fire on this
girl right here just to see.
And once we got the fight
stopped, and she's waiting--
and what's she waiting for?
AUDIENCE: Punishment.
AUDIENCE: Reaction.
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE: She's
waiting to go to the office.
She's waiting for the referral.
And I said, sit your ass down.
Fuck up my 18 years.
[LAUGHTER]
Sit your ass down.
And you know what
her reaction was?
She literally says, no.
You have to send
me to the office.
And I said, I don't send
people to the office.
Because when I was your age,
I got sent to the office.
You're here because I love
you, and you did some shit
that makes me want to kill you.
[LAUGHTER]
And so we're going to have
to go from kill to love.
And in order for that to
happen, we're going to talk.
No, you've got to
send me to the office.
No, I don't.
That's how our
relationship started.
And a year later, she's
telling that story.
Now I know how practical that
is, because this work ain't
always practical, right?
It's not clean.
It's not [INAUDIBLE].
Can you coach
people into the mess
and then create the conditions
whereby they can narrate,
how do I get out of this mess?
Perry can give you
some good stuff.
"Unnatural Causes" can
give you some good stuff.
But at the end of the
day, what I find is
most teachers already know
what they're supposed to do.
They're just loath to
do it, because they
haven't figured out how to
find themselves in that child.
So the practical
piece I will give you
is actually from my ancestors.
So I come from the
[INAUDIBLE],, which
connects me to the Mayan
and the [INAUDIBLE] people.
And the Mayans had a story, a
principle called In Lak'ech.
And In Lak'ech became an
increasingly popularized
concept and term in education
because of the work of the Raza
Studies program in Tucson
Unified who taught me a lot
about my history and my
culture and In Lak'ech.
And In Lak'ech the story
of the smoking mirror.
We would teach all our
children this idea.
And the idea is
that every living
being that you come across
is a smoking mirror.
That is not the question.
The question is
whether or not you
can muster the courage,
character, and commitment
to clear the smoke away.
Because if you do,
what will you see?
You'll see yourself.
That's the barrier
for most teachers.
Lisa Delpit called it
in one of her books,
"Other People's Children."
And as long as they're
other people's children,
they go to the office.
As long as they're
other people's children,
they go to juvie.
They need tough love.
They need discipline.
They need punishment.
But if it's your son,
if it's your daughter,
the smoke is cleared.
You know.
You'll try every angle, every--
you ain't going to the office.
There is no way in hell I'm
sending Amaru or Taiyari
to the damn principal.
They're my sons.
I feel that way about
every kid I teach.
You are my son.
You are my daughter.
I am not sending
you to somebody else
to fix you, because
you're not broken.
I have to figure out
what's in your way.
That is the principle teaching
of all of our ancestors,
and we've lost our way
around that because we've
been become technocratic
and mechanical in teaching.
Teaching is about
relationships, and relationships
is about work and pain.
And the deepest
relationships we have
are with people that we
went through that pain.
We cleared the smoke away.
And the honest truth
is that the kids that
are going to be the
toughest to reach
are the ones with
the most smoke.
And that makes sense,
because they're on fire.
Their lives are on fire.
So it's going to be way
more smoke to clear.
Harder work to find
yourself in that child.
But if you've taught
as long as I have,
you know that those are
the kids that come back.
They're worth it.
But that's what we've got to
get teachers to understand.
And a lot of times, it's about
getting early wins, right?
Don't start with the kid
that's a house of fire.
[LAUGHTER]
Start with the kid [INAUDIBLE]
a little bit of smoke.
Get an early win.
Start getting some momentum.
Get your confidence up that you
know how to build relationships
with these young
people, and then we
can build up to the kid
that's in full-on flames.
You dig?
[LAUGHTER]
Cool.
SPEAKER 1: Unfortunately, we
have now hit the end of our--
JEFF DUNCAN-ANDRADE:
Ha ha, that's
what happens when you
ask me a question.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]